[Musique]
alors plusieurs coups de coeur cette
semaine un peu comme d'habitude aussi 17
mai bon l'actualité fait que c'est ainsi
donc cette semaine c'est le début du
festival contre champ où les femmes sont
à l'honneur puisque la thématique du
festival cette année ces femmes rebelles
donc si vous le souhaitez vous pourrez
venir découvrir vendredi à 20h45 en
avant première le très beau film
mignonne qui sera précédée d'une petite
conférence sur les femmes dans le cinéma
et d'un petit pot de l'amitié comprendra
tous ensemble autre avant première cette
semaine au ciné cette le très réussi de
gaulle avec lambert wilson sur la vie le
cheminement du général de gaulle que
tout le monde connaît et enfin le coup
de coeur du ciné 7 cinéma cette semaine
c'est un film qui a déjà sorti à trois
semaines très beau film de léo karman
qui s'appelle la dernière vie de simon
dont venez voir ce film on va le garder
au ciné cette parce qu'on le soutient
parce qu'on aime les eaux et on aime son
film c'est un très beau film de genre un
très beau premier film je précise
fantastique très réussi d'aucuns disent
que les os et le nouveau et spielberg
c'est tout ce qu'on lui souhaite
mais c'est un film avec des acteurs pas
connu peu connus tour le propre frère de
léo martin karman qui s'en tirent
remarquablement et il est vraiment à
découvrir une très très belle histoire
je vous en dis pas plus mais vous on a
une 6 6 séances cette semaine au 6 et 7
donc venez nous vous attendons avec
plaisir
[Musique]